roman is from kharkiv a city in ruin
from russian attacks
he's at the border to let go of
everything he loves
turn back alone and join the fight
strzok
feelings fear confusion hate anger i
don't even know
one feeling is i i need to send my
family to safety
and next
next everything will be all right we
will win for sure
nothing else
we will save our country everything will
be all right
you don't have to know what he's saying
to understand how he feels
a country torn in two
small villages and towns like this one
are the last hurdle to safety for the
hundreds of thousands of men women and
children
amassing at poland's border
the last checkpoint the last long line
a last chance to say goodbye
the lucky ones board buses bound for
cities in europe others wait
this line is long but it is still moving
a week into this conflict and
the crowd the traffic the the line at
this border crossing it's much smaller
and the system of getting across into
poland seems much more organized much
more efficient but no less tragic for
the people that are leaving their
country behind
ukrainians trying to get to safety say
they feel abandoned by the international
community
they know help is coming but not enough
to stop russian invaders destroying
their cities their homes their lives
ukrainians are going to nato but nato is
not here in ukraine we need real help
army weapons helmets and west our army
needs serious help
they really need weapons and there is no
weapon in ukraine that would really
destroy the russians
each of these women have a husband or
father or brother fighting to defend
their cities or on the front line
they say they will never leave
and help other ukrainians however they
can
at a place that divides two countries
ukrainian families are being forced to
divide themselves
women move forward to preserve the
country's future
men go back to make sure they have a
home to come back to
zain basravi al-jazeera shigenya ukraine